طيب نحن كمراقبين تعودنا انه قبل
الانتخابات فتره الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والانتخابات النصفيه يكون هناك حاله من
الخطاب والخطاب المضاد حاله من الاستفزاز
بين الجانبين ولكن
نشعر بان حاله الاستقطاب اصبحت اكثر عمقا
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الان اذا
كان هذا صحيح ما الذي اوصل الولايات
المتحده الى هذه الدرجه من الاستغفار
في المجتمع الامريكي امرا صحيحا ومن جهتي
اذكر عندما كتب من الاداره الكثير من
السجالات بين الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين
وعدم الاتفاق بينهما وهي التي جعلتني
اقتنع بان الحسبه الديمقراطي قد ضحى الى
اقصى اليسار ونقاش هنا هنا بشان سياسه
الطاقه هو مثال جيد ودليل سارق على ذلك كم
مقاربتهم هنا والقائمه على غلقه انابيب
نقل الطاقه وصاحب الدعم للمصافي والمنشات
ادت الى تدمير الصناعه التي تحمل على
كتفها كل القطاعات الاخرى وهو قرار المدمر
بل ينطوي على الكثير من الغباء ونحن نرى
كم كان القرار غبيا لدرجه ان اداره وجدت
نفسها في وضع اليائس وتلقي باللوم على
غيرها في تبعاته وللاسف فانه هناك شخصيات
داخل هذا الحزب اصواتها عاليه تنتمي لاقصر
يسار او لاجدده لا تخدم بلادنا لديكم
ممتاز والهان عمر ورشيده طالب مثل هذه
الاصوات هناك اصوات تردد الصدى اقصى
اليسار وتدفع نحوه نرى مثلا
ومن المؤسف اند جو بايدنا الذي كان رمز
الوسط في الحزب الديمقراطي يعتلي منصب
الرئيس فيمنح الحسبه لاقصى اليسار هذا هو
الوضع كما نراه من جانب الحزب الديمقراطي
ومن جانب الحزب الجمهوري نرى انه تغير
بكيفيه جاذريه ودونالد ترامب اعاده تشكيل
الحزب باضافه شعبويه ويهتم اكثر بطبقات
العامله وتدعو سياسته هجره الحدود
المفتوحه وتطبيها هذه السياسات لا اعرف ما
اذا كان البعض سيعتبرها توجهها اكثر نحو
اليمين ولكن اعتقد ان دونالد ترامب اظهر
للعالم ان ذلك انعكاس الاكثر تمثيلا
لتوجهات الناخب الامريكي وانتظارته من
الحزب الجمهوريه اشكرك جزيل الشكر اليكم
على مشاركتك معنا